now by Labour's shadow chief secretary
to the treasury is chris leslie and a
very good morning to mr. lacy now first
of all want to pick up on this because
you wanted some straight answers to
straight questions I wanted it to about
conservative spending and Taxation plans
and the Chancellor seeming to rule out
the the issue of putting up there oh
sorry cutting the 45 p higher rate said
he had no plan well look it was
interesting wasn't it i just heard the
Chancellor and it was two years ago that
he decided it was a priority for people
earning over a hundred and fifty
thousand pounds a year to cut that rate
of income tax from 50p to 45p even
though the deficit has been considerable
he when you asked him a moment ago he
repeated that same formula I have no
plans well of course those are the same
that's the same formula he had before
the last general election when he said
oh we have no plans on v80 and of course
they did it I think what you've managed
to do here is flush out the Chancellor
their priority is always about helping
the very richest in society since that
tax cut was made two years ago if you
were earning a million pounds a year
maybe not on your on your salary lanaya
but if you were earning a million pounds
a year you've had a tax cut of 85,000
pounds and value now contrast that with
what's been happening with the rest of
the population who've seen their taxes
rise by 1100 s nice but I mean but let's
just look around you know the v80 pledge
which we did get from the Prime Minister
a couple of weeks ago aren't labour just
flashing around here the stump think to
scaremonger about and you know they grew
about the Conservatives ruled out
putting up v80 unequivocally now you're
landing on this well I think we're
trying to find out what the
Conservatives priorities are I mean we
know they've set out their trajectory
for spending cuts which go way beyond
what's necessary to deal with the
deficit they've got their ideological
desire to shrink that public investment
now the question is if it's really
tenable that they're going to take the
knife just public services that much I
think the public will resist it and if
they're not going to do that well that's
why we're asking about their alternative
tax bands I'm not sure I believe them on
vaat but you're attacking them on that
but I mean the thing about the thing
with everything they ask you but I've
got to ask you about it is national
insurance plans no plans or absolutely
categorically rule out any increase in
national insurance absolutely
new rule it out yeah absolutely we've
said that and we don't need to do it the
reason we don't need to do it is because
we've got a more balanced approach we're
focused on the deficit their focus the
conservative focus very much more on
getting to that excessive extreme
surplus that they want because they have
a desire to shrink back and public
spending and it's a different strategy
now we believe that we can deal with the
deficit through a combination yes of
some spending cuts fairer tax changes
that's why we've set up there a side of
things that well no well it's not i
think we don't need to go down the route
that the Conservatives have gone there
their cuts are going to be twice as deep
over the next three years as they've
been over the next 5 on page 16 of the
office for budget responsibility
document in the budget you'll see the
graph is very very silly little develop
roller coaster if you remember going
over that edge we don't think that is
necessary because we would put that top
right of tax for the very richest going
up to 50 but I mean yeah I think that's
a big contrast now we know that the
conservatives believe in trickle-down
they want the thing that magically
helping the richest I'm not a people are
going to be cocaleros everybody else
we've got to bring in the SNP here
because of a lot of what they're saying
on the economies it's like they had to
go to what you're saying though you know
why do you say to Nicola Sturgeon yes of
course you're going to win some seats
we're going to try and prevent you
inning as many as we can but of course
you're gonna have a lot of seats there
we could form this anti-austerity well
I'm not sure quite what the snps AI mean
they say one thing i do but they say
another thing it appears in minutes i
don't know quite what was going on there
but it you know i think a lot of people
are not surprised that you know the
revelations that perhaps Nicola Sturgeon
actually does secretly want to
conservative government why do they want
that well they'd love to get into a
second referendum and look at
jeopardizing the union in this way I you
know the SNP and the Conservatives I
think are playing political games with
our country's future what we've got to
do is make sure that we protect our
public services as best we possibly can
Nicholas virgin so also have fairer
taxes on the very rich what's good and
safe she believed I'm an appointee that
why didn't it open it what you do have
the reality of how you do don't you deal
with the reality and if Nicola Sturgeon
still keeps saying exactly the same
things you're saying the electorate are
going to say well why don't you get
they're in some way shape or no we've
ruled out a coalition with ESPN the
other way we don't believe in doing that
with them because they believe in
totally different things and breaking up
the United Kingdom we don't believe in
that but obviously I'm hoping we will
have a Labour government we will put our
program before the House of Commons even
if we can get liberals conservatives
whoever it is to vote for that program
we'd like them to vote for that that
means getting rid of the bedroom tax
that means putting on that 50p raid but
of course nicola sturgeon and her mps
they didn't turn up when we have the
vote against those conservative spending
plans that that extreme cuts of twice
the depth that we've seen in the last
five years and I don't know why they
didn't turn up so chief secretary thank
you very much to be very good to see you
Chris Leslie they're from labor now come